merci d'être avec nous François Noël
buffet nous accompagner pendant cette
première demi-heure sénateur les
républicains du Rhône vous présidez la
commission des lois ici au Sénat on va
parler de l'audition hier de Gérald
Darmanin que vous avez mené mais d'abord
la réforme des retraites et on l'a vu
c'est donc un échec de la réunion entre
Elisabeth borne et les syndicats qui
responsables de cet échec selon vous
c'était pas surprenant
il y a une manifestation prévue le
lendemain tout le monde attend la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel que
pouvait-on espérer de ce rendez-vous sur
votre positif on dit que moi le dialogue
s'est rétabli entre le gouvernement et
les syndicats après pour le reste je
crois que c'est suspendu le temps est
suspendu suspendu effectivement
aujourd'hui parce que les syndicats
veulent montrer qu'ils sont encore
mobilisés et suspendu à la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel peut-être sur
que laquelle on fait porter beaucoup
d'espoir et sans forcément de grandes
certitudes nous verrons bien
une possibilité de censure c'est
difficile de juger
constitutionnels mais globalement on
sait quelles sont les points forts du
texte et quels sont les points un peu
plus faibles donc on se doute bien
qu'ils vont réagiter de quelques points
et vous ne croyez pas la censure totale
je n'y crois pas non à priori je ne
crois pas la sauce sur total ou alors
tous les cas ce serait une très grande
surprise donc le temps est suspendu
néanmoins il fallait malgré tout qu'ils
se reparle alors évidemment la première
rencontre n'est pas très positive mais
néanmoins elle a eu lieu c'est déjà ça
gageons que à la faveur des décisions
qui arriveront la manifestation
d'aujourd'hui dont on peut imaginer
qu'elle sera encore effectivement une
journée de mobilisation importante la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
figera à la situation et donc peut-être
que le dialogue pourra se réouvrir sur
le fond un peu plus sérieusement la
semaine prochaine voilà que pouvons nous
dire de plus chacun est un peu dans sa
position dans les acteurs de de ces
affaires là c'est dommage d'en arriver
là on voit pas mais si le Conseil
constitutionnel ne censure pas
totalement le texte et que donc Emmanuel
Macron promulgue la réforme est-ce que
vous craignez une radicalisation des
violences des manifestations et donc de
la violence je crois d'où l'important
alors il faut distinguer les choses une
fois ça reviendra à la discussion qu'on
aura avec l'audition d'hier
manifestant des syndicats manifestent
dans le calme il y a pas de difficulté
particulière c'est pas eux qui mettent
le bazar c'est Black Blocs c'est des
gens d'extrême gauche
l'ultra gauche qu'on appelle l'ultra
gauche c'est des gens violents qui
viennent par la violence donc ne
mélangeons pas les choses tout de même
donc gageons que si la décision du
Conseil constitutionnelle est de
confirmer en grande partie du très
majoritaire en le texte que les
partenaires sociaux et louanement
retrouvent les les fils du dialogue et
recommence à tisser quelque chose
naturellement ça sera pas dans la nuit
la situation il y a des sujets abordés
sur le fond
la pénibilité les carrières longues il y
a encore beaucoup de travail à faire la
notion du travail quelle est la
définition du travail aujourd'hui
comment on peut pas parler de Satan qui
a pas de retard mais on comprend bien et
ils attendent et bien une fois que les
choses sont faites peut-être que les
choses avanceront tous les cas il faut
le souhaiter pour le pays et pour tout
le monde naturel est-ce qu'on est dans
une crise démocratique comme le dit
Laurent Berger je ne crois pas les mots
ont un sens en n'est pas dans un pays
comme le nôtre ou les institutions
fonctionnent elles sont ce qu'elles sont
aussi des gens mais elles fonctionnent
ce sont les acteurs qui font fonctionner
les institutions ce sont pas
institutions elles-mêmes donc le système
démocratique fonctionne vous pouvez
manifester vous pouvez dire ce que vous
voulez mais il y a un moment évidemment
il y a un système de décision ce système
de décision c'est la démocratie
représentative donc à partir de ce
moment-là on a élu des gens pour ça des
députés des sénateurs et c'est eux qui
tranchent au bout du compte c'est comme
ça que ça fonctionne je connais pas
d'autres systèmes plus démocratiques qui
peut y avoir d'autres mais les autres
certains systèmes sont plutôt à
l'inverse des dictatures donc gardons
bien le nôtre faisons fonctionner les
choses normalement mais non n'allons pas
trop loin quand même dans les propos qui
sont tenus
le 11ème journée de mobilisation on l'a
dit on va parler de la stratégie du
maintien de l'ordre dans quelques
instants mais 11500 policiers gendarmes
sont mobilisés aujourd'hui pour cette
journée de mobilisation c'est un
dispositif à même d'éviter les
débordements pour vous les cas ça peut
paraître comme un dispositif suffisant
pour voir contenir les choses essayer de
régler le problème on imagine bien que
le calibrage si je peux me permettre de
cette expression a été fait par le
ministère de l'Intérieur à la faveur
d'information et malheureusement
d'expérience comme vous dites c'est la
11e manifestation 11e jour de grève
quand il y a quand même une expérience
qui a été acquise il faut espérer que
les choses se passent bien mais vous
savez l'affaire des Black Blocs les
Ultra violences ce sont des petits
groupes ils sont pas ils sont importants
mais nombreux mais très mobiles et donc
c'est toutes ces difficultés qu'il faut
gérer et on va en parler justement
puisque vous avez additionné hier le
ministre de l'Intérieur en général
Darmanin sur cette stratégie du maintien
de l'ordre on va voir les temps forts de
cette audition avec Audrey Vittaz
[Musique]
bonjour
et Audrey la commission des lois que
vous présidez François annel buffet donc
auditionné Gérald Darmanin le ministre
de l'Intérieur hier au sujet des
manifestations et du maintien de l'ordre
dans les manifestations contre la
réforme des retraites mais aussi à
Sainte solide qu'est-ce qu'on peut en
retenir et bien le ministre a défendu sa
stratégie de maintien de l'ordre pendant
les manifestations donc et contre et
pendant la manifestation à
Sainte-Souline Sainte-Souline ou 48
gendarmes et 200 manifestants ont été
blessés l'un d'entre eux et d'ailleurs
toujours entre la vie et la mort d'après
Gérald Darmanin s'il y a une
augmentation de la violence n'est pas un
problème de maintien de l'Orbe c'est
parce que l'ultra gauche prend selon lui
en otage le mouvement social notamment
il y voit un basculement à partir du 16
mars le jour de l'emploi du 49-3 à
l'Assemblée nationale l'ultra gauche qui
était aussi présente en nombre d'après
lui à Sainte-Souline écouter
nous nous préparions à un moment de
confrontation non pas parce que nous le
souhaitions comme je l'entends ici ou là
mais parce qu'il était inévitable
puisque personne n'a respecté l'État de
droit dans le camp des manifestants
casseurs ni les arrêtés d'interdiction
de la préfète ni les arrêter de
transport d'armes d'après le ministre de
l'Intérieur 800 objets auraient été
saisis par les policiers gendarmes
couteaux boules de pétanque hache alors
de manière générale la droite
sénatoriale et du côté des forces de
l'ordre ça n'a pas empêché votre
collègue le Kester Philippe Bas d'être
un petit peu acerbe avec le gouvernement
écouté
tout ce que vous nous avez démontré
montre que ce qui s'est produit était
prévisible
qu'avez-vous fait pour l'empêcher
c'était interdit mais où est l'autorité
de l'État quand l'interdiction n'est pas
respectée et que vous ne vous donnez pas
les moyens d'empêcher ce que vous
interdisez il me semble que nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans une situation où l'État
est défié certes mais qu'il est aussi
peut-être déficient les personnes n'ont
pas réussi à installer de ZAD et oui
l'autorité de l'État a été respectée
mais oui cela a été violent et oui il
faut se prévenir contre cela
François Noël buffet est-ce que
l'autorité de l'État a été respectée à
Sainte Soline
l'autorité de l'État au bout du bout la
manifestation qui était interdite avec
une vocation d'ailleurs qui a pour
vocation détruire ce qu'on appelle les
grands réservoirs d'eau et d'occuper les
lieux et de créer une ZAD oui si on s'en
tient à ça l'objectif est atteint ils
n'ont pas pu s'installer ce qu'on peut
regretter c'est la manière dont ça s'est
passé évidemment que il aurait été bien
meilleur de pouvoir empêcher les choses
que cette manifestation cette
manifestation ne se tiennent pas
malheureusement ça n'a pas été possible
pourquoi c'était pas n'a été possible
parce que les personnes qui étaient
venues pour manifester étaient pas venu
simplement pour manifester certaines
d'entre elles étaient venus pour casser
pour tuer pour blesser les forces de
l'ordre donc à un moment évidemment que
le la réaction des forces de l'ordre est
difficile moi ce que je pense c'est que
nous devons pas nous laisser aller un
commentaire facile mais qu'en revanche
nous devons être très ferme sur le
respect de l'ordre et de la règle
républicaine cela ce sera dit comment ça
veut dire que les forces de l'ordre ont
une discipline des façons de faire avec
des règles qui doivent être respectées
naturellement que individuellement il
peut y avoir des difficultés et il faut
pas les laisser passer ça il y a aucun
doute là-dessus mais qu'on peut pas non
plus laisser les forces de l'ordre qui
sont des concitoyens comme vous et moi
se laisser caillasser se laisser viser
par des systèmes de fusée se laisser
attaquer par DH par des couteaux enfin
dans quel monde vit-on est-ce qu'on va
tolérer cela il y a un moment il y a une
échelle des valeurs et la valeur elle
est plutôt du côté de l'ordre
républicain et du respect des règles de
la République pas de la violence de
l'attaque de l'agression pour ne pas
dire autre chose on est vraiment dans
des moments où il y a des moments de
délictuel voire parfois criminel quand
vous apprenez que des gendarmes ont été
brûlés à eu les jambes brûlées à l'acide
je sais pas une manifestation pacifique
donc ne nous trompons pas sur l'échelle
des valeurs ensuite que dans cet échec
des valeurs il y a des règles et
qu'elles soient respectées c'est évident
dans notre monde sinon on n'en sortira
pas mais véritablement
cette période la prudence dans l'usage
des mots est fondamentale et dans les
âges des punchlines et autres comprend
bien que les certains tout le monde veut
exister sur ces sujets là mais attention
à ne pas en rajouter trop et voir
au-delà de la réalité au bout du bout
qui est l'enjeu l'enjeu c'est notre
ordre républicain c'est notre capacité à
vivre ensemble à manifester contre
manifester mais pas ce que nos forces de
l'ordre qui que ce soit d'autre se
prennent un pavé sur la tête voir une
balle voir un coup de hache ou un coup
de couteau voir de l'acide donc ça c'est
non et force doit rester à la loi c'est
la règle sinon ça veut dire que tout est
possible et qui a plus d'organes
d'organisation démocratique il y a plus
de lien social possible il y a plus de
vie en commun c'est pas possible or ceux
qui sont venus une grande partie était
des gens qui venaient aussi un peu de
l'international d'un peu tous les pays
était parfaitement organisé parfaitement
structuré sur le but de poursuivi le
ministre moi je défends pas
particulièrement ni les années les
autres mais je regarde ce qu'il dit ces
documenté ce qu'il a dit et documenté
donc ce n'est pas une ville d'esprit
c'est une réalité ces conditions-là on
ne peut être que de son côté en revanche
telle personne
qui représente l'autorité publique
commet des actes qui n'a pas à commettre
évidemment qu'il n'y a pas de faiblesse
à avoir à son endroit Audrey la gauche a
vivement critiqué Gérald Darmanin dans
cette position oui on parlait de
l'importance des mots ça a donné lieu à
une passe d'armes assez virulente entre
la sénatrice socialiste Marie-Pierre de
la Gonterie est le ministre de
l'Intérieur écoutez vous avez fait la
une du JDD je vous en félicite sans
doute en indiquant que vous refusiez de
céder au terrorisme intellectuel de
l'extrême gauche tu élu de Paris le
terme de terrorisme pour chaque Français
d'ailleurs et quelque chose que vous ne
devriez pas utiliser de manière un peu
rapide vous n'êtes pas la police des
mots madame de La grotterie vous faites
partie manifestants du camp du Bien et
vous vous considérez qu'il des gens qui
peuvent utiliser des mots et d'autres
qui ne peuvent pas le faire il n'y a pas
de police des mots en démocratie madame
la sédatrice oui quand on dit que les
policiers doivent se faire rééduquer
mentalement comme le dit Monsieur
Lanchon c'est une forme de terreur et
terrorisme intellectuelle c'est certain
François le buffet c'est le bon mot
terrorisme en tous les cas ça ne m'a pas
choqué particulièrement évidemment que
nous associons ceci aux actions
terroristes de l'islam radical mais
l'usage dans notre dans notre pays c'est
d'utiliser ce mot parfois à d'autres
fins c'est pas quelque chose qui me
choque en revanche ce qui me
profondément et c'est ce que l'on peut
constater c'est que il y a une forme de
de débat sémantique de
de propagation d'idées qui consiste à au
prêt-à-penser et à considérer que il y a
effectivement parfois le bien à côté le
mal de l'autre et que tout ça n'est pas
discutable c'est pas la vie ça et puis
on sait que pour des raisons politiques
certains mouvements notamment de gauche
ou d'extrême gauche utilise cela de
façon à former les pensées à obliger à
considérer que les gens doivent penser
de la même façon et qu'il y a pas
d'autres manières de penser attention à
ces actions politiques ou à cette façon
de faire la politique qui est
naturellement ont une autre vocation que
celle qu'elle veut bien avouer et qui
est une vocation à finalement percolé
dans le pays et amener les gens à croire
ce qu'on leur dit sans avoir de capacité
de critique donc toujours gardons cette
distance là et ne nous laissons pas
embarquer là dedans parce que ça finira
mal donc attention à cela je crois que
la prudence est nécessaire et justement
les mots justes c'est ce qui me paraît
la meilleure solution pour se sortir de
ces situations qui sont j'ose pas dire
explosives ce serait maladroit pour le
coup mais qui sont des situations de
tension qui n'ont pas lieu d'être un
point aussi sur la Ligue des droits de
l'homme puisque ça a beaucoup fait
réagir hier Gérald de Darmanin a laissé
entendre que les subventions publiques
accordées à l'association pourrait être
remises en cause alors pour le contexte
il répondait à François bonhomme
sénateur à parenté les républicains qui
estiment que l'association remet en
cause l'état droit écouter la réponse du
ministre
de l'homme je connais pas les
subventions données par l'État mais
effectivement je pense que ça mérite ça
mérite d'être regardé dans le cadre des
actions qu'ils ont pu mener mais je
rappelle que beaucoup de collectivités
locales aussi des finances
voilà non mais je dis représentant des
collectivités locales également que vous
êtes voilà donc ce n'est pas qu'une
question il n'y a pas que l'État quel
est votre avis là-dessus parce que c'est
quand même une association qui défend
les droits et les libertés depuis 30 ans
de la distance sortons d'un débat en
commission avec les interventions des
uns des autres alors du soleil des
droits de l'homme et parfaitement connu
on sait comment ça fonctionne voilà bon
on reste calme c'est une association
respectable et dans son rôle une fois de
plus qu'on est le dialogue c'est la même
chose quand vous voyez que
sous-entendre qu'il allait regarder s'il
fallait marquer les subventions de
l'État
la réponse est sans doute maladroite
mais c'est la même chose quand on en
parle du Conseil de l'Europe et de la
commission la commissaire qui s'est
exprimée voire même d'autres
même la Défenseur des droits par exemple
que je respecte par ailleurs je crois
que là aussi il y a besoin d'un dialogue
entre les institutions et il est pas
inutile que nous allions les rencontrer
discuter avec elle comprendre ce qu'il
en est de façon à ce que il est cette
nature ça ne sert à rien nous sommes
allés que la commission des lois il n'y
a pas très longtemps à la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme nous
sommes allés au Conseil de l'Europe il y
a une quinzaine de jours trois semaines
peut-être nous sommes allés rencontrer
tous ces intervenants parce qu'on veut
comprendre comment il fonctionne comment
il nous regarde et ça a été très
productif et c'est très utile pour nous
à la commission donc voilà il suffit que
les gens discutent un peu donc dans ce
climat de tension mais bien sûr que ça
marche dans les deux sens évidemment
compris comment vous fonctionnez comment
fonctionne les stratégies du maintien de
langue en tous les cas on leur a fait
passer des messages on leur a dit
comment les choses étaient eux-mêmes ont
besoin de comprendre et et nous on a
besoin de comprendre aussi quelles sont
leurs positions si vous n'instaurez pas
ces discussions qui ne veut pas dire
qu'on a pas des convictions qu'on n'est
pas ferme qu'on n'est pas déterminé à
faire des choses il y a un moment ça
devient ce qu'on appelle un dialogue de
sourd il y a rien de pire que ça parce
qu'effectivement du dialogue de sourd ne
peut souvent
apparaître que la violence
l'incompréhension et au bout du compte
le grand n'importe quoi donc il faut
sortir de ça il faut accepter qu'on
puisse discuter une fois de plus ça n'en
met en cause le fait qu'on est ferme sur
les règles que l'on défend et sur les
objectifs que l'on
poursuites dans le club merci Audrey on
va parler de la loi immigration
franchement elle lui fait puisque vous
avez travaillé dessus vous avez fait un
rapport sénatorial sur le sujet mais
vous aviez aussi travailler sur la loi
qui devait être examiné la semaine
dernière au Sénat qui a finalement été
reportée est-ce que vous savez ce que le
texte va devenir est-ce que vous en avez
reparlé avec Gérald Darmanin au moment
où je vous parle je ne sais pas
pour tout vous dire on a une conférence
des présidents hier soir
cela n'a pas été en face le sujet était
abordé mais nous attendons en réalité
les arbitrages qui doivent intervenir
entre la première ministre et le
président de la République qui a
plusieurs textes importants avant l'été
la loi de programmation militaire
notamment on parle d'une loi travail on
nous parle d'autres textes sur l'énergie
le texte immigration donc sur la fin de
vie et naturellement quoi que le
Président de la République a demandé un
texte rédigé pas forcément présenté au
Parlement avant l'été donc nous sommes
dans l'attente nous savons que le mois
de mai et le mois de juin sont des mois
importants en termes d'ordre du jour
gouvernemental donc pour l'instant nous
sommes suspendus faut-il le regretter la
réponse est quand même oui nous avons la
commission des lois
avant l'été ce serait quand même l'idéal
parce que c'est important les sujets
sont fondamentaux les règles à modifier
sont essentielles et donc il faut qu'on
avance c'est un sujet qui est attendu
qu'il soit pas placé dans une situation
d'ambiance générale un peu confituelle
on peut le comprendre mais ça ne peut
pas durer donc il faut maintenant qu'on
continue d'avancer la commission des
lois c'est déjà prononcée le texte doit
venir en séance et bien écoutez qu'on le
refixe et qu'on est le débat alors
avancer mais sous quelle forme le
président de la République a parlé d'un
projet de loi et de plusieurs
propositions de loi sous quelle forme
vous souhaitez je suis partisan je l'ai
dit de conserver un texte unique pour
quelle raison pour la raison de la
cohérence bien sûr pour des raisons de
cohérence
il était retiré pour des raisons de
circonstances pas pour des raisons de
fond il était retiré par exemple
circonstances donc gardons ce texte faut
qu'il soit cohérent celui qui sort de la
commission des lois me paraît
parfaitement a été nettement amélioré
par la commission des lois il y a de la
cohérence donc allons au débat et qu'on
le fasse sérieusement mais sans crainte
non plus ah il a été durci le texte que
vous avez examiné en commission des lois
vous l'avez durci sur la partie de
sherald Darmanin mais il y a toujours ce
point qui pose problème à la droite
sénatoriale quelle est la question des
titres de séjour accordé aux
travailleurs dans les métiers en tension
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire mais là
encore c'est un faux problème parce que
pour le coup on est dirigeait moins très
bien
il y a pas de difficulté pour régler le
problème des métiers en tension si le
gouvernement voulait régulariser un
certain nombre de situations il peut le
faire sans avoir à légiférer en passant
par les préfets qui ont la possibilité
de pouvoir régularité je pense que le
plus simple est de le retirer
effectivement retirer cet article et
puis le gouvernement donnera
l'instruction qui veut au préfet il y a
des conditions à respecter de pas faire
n'importe quoi évidemment mais il n'y a
pas besoin de texte pour ça alors s'il
s'agissait d'afficher dans le texte
qu'on veut régulariser pour donner des
gages et bien c'est raté on retire et
puis on fait le reste on a besoin de
cette cohérence on a besoin de renforcer
l'apprentissage du français le respect
des République on a besoin de d'avoir
une immigration choisie et non pas une
migration subie c'est fondamental on a
besoin de simplifier les règles de
procédure tout en respectant les droits
de la défense évidemment on a besoin
d'être très très fermes à l'égard de
l'immigration irrégulière mais le texte
initial n'allait pas assez loin pour
vous non mais le texte de la commission
des lois me semble beaucoup plus
équilibré et beaucoup plus vous allez
dire cohérent avec différents poursuivre
à suivre le gouvernement écouter de quoi
ce que je veux entendu on pouvait avoir
quelques discussions sur certains points
mais qui pouvaient avancer après ce qui
se passera l'Assemblée nationale est une
autre affaire justement Olivier Marley
sur ce plateau nous disait il y a
quelques jours que le députés les
républicains réfléchissaient à une
proposition de loi sur la question de
l'immigration vous en avez parlé avec
eux
en a parlé longtemps moi j'ai moi-même
préparé un texte à l'automne que j'ai
gardé dans mon cartable en disant on
demandera le texte du Gouvernement mais
j'ai toujours mon texte dans mon
cartable
ressortir je peux sortir quand on veut
et qu'est-ce que vous avez dit alors
avec Olivier Marley c'est pas un peu
dommage que chacun ait son texte
naturellement avec la proposition qu'on
pourrait faire au Sénat si elle devait
aller un peu plus loin on la partagerait
mais globalement on la partageons donc
il y a pas de difficulté particulière
là-dessus on va aller voir l'actualité
du côté de Lyon chez vous on retrouve
Maria trompette bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous directeur départemental
adjoint au progrès pour le pour le Rhône
Marien merci d'être avec nous alors on a
envie de vous demander Maria est-ce que
vous avez des nouvelles de votre
président de Région Laurent Wauquiez
justement si c'était une question que
j'avais envie de poser à Monsieur buffet
bonjour bonjour
Je on a l'impression quand même que
cette histoire autour de la réforme des
retraites va laisser des traces
certaines on a senti que le parti
c'était divisé notamment sur la notion
de censure
et puis dans la région où vous en
parliez Laurent Wauquiez est quand même
très très discret en ce moment
surtout sur ce sujet il s'est très peu
exprimé
je lui fais ce que vous pensez qu'il
aurait dû s'impliquer davantage
comment vous juger sa stratégie
aujourd'hui et puis est-ce qu'il est
toujours le mieux placé pour 2027
je pense d'abord bonjour pardon
je pense que le président de la Région
Laurent invoqué aurait
souhaité pour ma part qu'il puisse
effectivement s'exprimer pas forcément
dans des plumes incroyables mais au
moins donner son point de vue et dire
les choses oui mais c'est son choix je
le respecte j'aurais moi-même préféré
que il soit candidat à la du mouvement
je lui avais dit d'ailleurs mais je
contacte donc c'est son choix il a il a
pris la décision de se placer en retrait
médiatique néanmoins je crois savoir que
il fait beaucoup de déplacements et sur
le terrain et il est en immersion dans
un certain nombre de secteurs c'est une
bonne chose bien sûr mais c'est vrai que
de temps en temps on aimerait l'entendre
un peu plus voilà bon c'est un regret
personnel mais une fois de plus il est
seul je crois qu'il a décidé en tous les
cas c'est ce que je comprends de passer
plus de temps sur le terrain à la
rencontre des Français dans différents
secteurs très diverses pour pour prendre
véritablement le coût de la situation il
a raison de le faire c'est fondamental
il a parfaitement raison de le faire
mais de temps en temps un petit message
nous ferait plaisir
sur la question de Maria est-ce que dans
ces conditions il peut encore être votre
candidat en 2020 vous savez l'élection
présidentielle c'est en demi dans 2027
nous avons encore quatre ans au moment
où l'actualité se joue quasiment de jour
en jour d'heure en heure les situations
évoluent mais rien n'est impossible
n'ayant pas tranché sur une réforme
aussi importante dans le contexte mais
bien évidemment donc de ce point de vue
là je pense que il a son programme il a
sa stratégie il va la dérouler je
l'imagine bien mais il y a d'autres
personnes chez les LR qui pourraient
être que la question est moins une
question de personne qu'une question
d'incarnation de la fonction et de la
capacité à porter un projet donc quand
on aura la personnalité capable de
porter un projet et d'incarner la
fonction n'aura pas de difficulté le
robotique fait partie de cela évidemment
cherche à élargir la majorité c'est la
mission que elle confie Emmanuel Macron
est-ce qu'il faut que les républicains
fassent un pas vers le gouvernement moi
j'ai déjà dit ce que j'en pensais de
cette situation là ce n'est pas
forcément
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de il n'est pas souhaitable
que les mouvements extrémistes de droite
comme de gauche puisse arriver au
pouvoir le système démocratique étant ce
qu'il est aujourd'hui pourrait
éventuellement l'envisager à ce
moment-là il appartient à ceux qui ont
l'intérêt général vient cheville au
corps et une autre vision de l'évolution
de notre pays de le moment venu
peut-être de le faire nous n'en sommes
pas encore là mais si ça devait être le
cas je le redis ça peut être que de
façon transparente Marion vous avez une
question pour François anal buffet sur
la fusion de deux communes en banlieue
de Lyon commune que qu'il connaît bien
oui monsieur
pendant 20 ans
il y a quelques semaines le progrès à
révéler que cette ville et sa voisine
Pierre Bénite avait comme projet de
fusionner notamment pour peser davantage
à la métropole qui à Lyon rappelons-le
et dirigé par les écologistes
moi j'ai cru comprendre monsieur buffet
que vous n'étiez pas forcément emballé
par ce mariage et surtout vous n'aviez
pas été consulté je crois que vous avez
parfaitement compris en réalité je suis
pas hostile aux fusion de communes bien
au contraire je pense qu'elles sont
nécessaires par moment il n'y a pas de
difficulté j'avais moi-même essayé à un
moment de
rapprocher la ville d'oullin de la ville
de La Mulatière pour des raisons
stratégiques parce qu'on a déjà une vie
commune notamment industrielle avec la
SNCF et parce qu'on s'orientait vers le
centre de la métropole donc sur le
principe je suis d'accord sur le fait
que je n'ai pas été associé à la
décision c'est une réalité c'est vrai je
l'ai appris parce qu'on m'a le maire de
Pierre-Bénite m'a téléphoné mais c'est
tout ensuite sur le fond monsieur buffet
par rapport comment j'imagine est-ce que
vous avez été vexé par ce finalement ce
manque de tact des élus de
j'ai été élu municipal pendant 30 ans
j'ai été adjoint au maire pendant deux
ans et j'ai été bien de la commune
pendant 20 ans réélu trois fois au
premier tour par les habitants d'Oullins
on a quand même un attachement à son
territoire et à ses habitants on a quand
même on ne sommes pas que des robots
contrairement à ce qu'on imagine on a un
peu d'affect bon mais cela il faut le
mettre de côté dans une circonstance et
puis malheureusement c'est comme ça mais
si on dépasse cette situation là
l'enjeu c'est de savoir quel est
l'intérêt de la ville d'où là je
comprends parfaitement l'intérêt de la
ville de Pierre-Bénite l'intérêt de la
ville d'Oullins je le comprends un peu
moins maintenant les mers se sont
engagés à eux de démontrer
l'intérêt de la fusion il faut un projet
il faut une idée de fond il faut une
ligne force donc cela moi je l'attends
j'ai rencontré les deux mères ces
dernières semaines et mon premier qui
aura un débat et mon premier qui aurait
des
propositions qui seraient faites et en
tous les cas qu'il y aurait
qu'il démontrerait l'intérêt à la mesure
et ben écoutez je suis dans l'attente de
cela merci Marion trompette d'avoir été
avec nous on regarde la une du progrès
la désillusions finales et la défaite de
Lyon que vous regrettez dramatique
c'est la éliminé de la Coupe de France
merci beaucoup Marion trompette d'avoir
été avec nous merci Françoise buffet
d'avoir été notre invité pendant cette
première demi-heure